you talk about
masculinity a lot that comes up a lot
does not come up on this podcast
for reasons that still Escape me
um no but but seriously John like you
you you talk about it and I think you
have
um uh uh it's you have a great it's a
it's a it's a great vantage point you
have because you can talk about it from
this place of having experienced you
know or having experience with toxic
masculinity or people thinking that
about you because of you know whatever
difficulties you've had in the past or
the or the fighting or whatever they can
just think like oh this guy's this is
the point of view this guy's going to be
coming at me from and then for you to
talk about how that is a can be a toxic
formula and is not the answer gives you
an authority in that I think that other
people
it gives you a power to talk about that
subject that maybe other people don't
have look I I don't know if I have any
any power in it and I don't honestly
with the the the the sort of terms that
people throw out there I you know I I
don't know I'm No Authority on that I
know that I'm a father and I'm a father
of two boys and and I know the kind of
men that I want them to grow up to be
and the kind of young men I want them to
be and I know the kind of models of
masculinity that I want them to see and
I think you know sometimes I've I've
talked about this before and I think
sometimes it gets confusing and I think
that I don't know I I don't know that
I've ever been
I do believe in in discipline I'm I'm
somebody my my kids you know they they
practice martial arts they know you you
know they they they
um know how to handle themselves in the
woods you know they I I I I really think
it's enormously important not for them
but also just as equally important for
my daughter to be able to defend
themselves and to be able to handle
themselves into like these things are
these sort of cornerstones of I think
you know classic masculinity are super
super important but equally important is
being kind is being empathetic is to
stand up for somebody who has less
rights than you somebody who's being
picked on somebody who's being put into
the corner somebody who's just sad uh
you know
um getting in touch with uh a side of
them that that softer Having the courage
to do that to to
um you know I I had a guy on on my show
that I've just learned so much from a
dear friend of mine named Kevin Vance
who's a Navy SEAL and a firefighter and
just one of the just just this wonderful
human being and he talks about the code
of the Samurai and how they yeah they
they knew how to fight and they knew how
to use swords and they were warriors but
they also had to get in touch with their
quote unquote feminine side and and
their ability to do calligraphy and to
dance and to cook and to garden and that
these things are all equally important
and and to be well-rounded but again
when it's confused with
being hardened or being uh a picking on
somebody or again saying it's my way or
the highway to me that is that reeks of
such fear and such insecurity yeah it's
a classic rule in the boxing gym I've
said it before when you come into Steve
Petra Molly's gym you're gonna see oh
I'm coming I know you are and I'm coming
in hard I know man well well loved it my
point is is that in the bar in any
boxing gym in this country you can see
it the guy who's the loudest the guy
with the brightest color clothes the guy
who's kind of you know dancing around
that's me that's all three oh look I
think that will change because I think
that that that that is almost always the
guy you don't need to worry about
who Smiles at you and shakes your hand
and nods and says hey man you want to
move a little bit like yeah you got deal
with this guy I'm coming in wearing uh
bright Shamrock shorts let's go and an
actual peacock tail yeah a peacock yeah
and a monocle I love it man uh no I uh
I'm I'm listen I want to get to make
sure I get help get the word out because
uh your podcast is doing well real ones
is uh available wherever people get
their podcast right yeah everywhere yes
Spotify and uh John Bernthal real ones
and it's very refreshing thanks because
you're talking to real people about real
things and you do have the touch you are
able to connect with these people I
think that's very cool and
um you know if you ever need help out
there in the world you know if you get
into a tight corner and you need a guy
to come in and swing these these meat
hooks around not him don't call me yeah
don't call me because I'm a terrible I
do not have your back
I'm being honest
honestly I love it I'm a kicker I'm a
guy who kicks and then runs great yeah a
little scratch maybe yeah a slap I I
can't make a fist uh but I slap and then
I run I'm a slap and run guy I love it